and the european commission is meeting
in brussels to finalize a sixth package
of eu sanctions in a major shift germany
says it will now back an immediate eu
embargo on russian oil
the eu has also warned member states to
prepare for a possible complete
breakdown in gas supplies from russia
insisting it would not cede to moscow's
demand to pay in rubles
akiv says russia's energy exports to
europe are funding the kremlin war in
ukraine with millions of euros every day
now russia provides roughly a quarter of
the natural gas consumed in the european
union more in some countries like
germany at the vast bulk of those
exports to the eu some 80 percent
flow across ukrainian soil
the government in kiev earns transit
fees from russia and is still in fact
despite the war the toll of the conflict
of course vastly outweighs those
revenues and that's why ukraine has been
impatient for the eu to end gas imports
from russia earlier today i spoke with
the ceo of ukraine's state-owned nafta
gas company yuri vatrenko i asked if
countries like germany were moving fast
enough
on one hand we are
grateful for the efforts
to decrease
imports of russian gas and oil that we
see at the moment we understand that
often it's not easy because
unfortunately
europe made itself to dependent on
russian gas and oil
finally at least it's happening as they
say better late than never so
europe and germany in particular and
germany is leading this way inside the
european union uh europe is decreasing
imports of russian case and oil but of
course it's not enough and we see it as
a matter of fact because this horrific
war continues and the civilians are
being killed as we speak so that is why
uh we need to do more
uh and in order to do more uh there are
many things that we all need to do so
that uh bloody putin regime stops
getting money from europe again to
finance its military to finance
its public support basically to finance
its regime
for more than throughout more than two
months of this conflict so far we've
seen that
gas infrastructure coming from russia
going through ukraine has not been
damaged in such a way as to limit the
gas coming into the eu
is there coordination between the
ukraine and russia to ensure that this
infrastructure remains untouched
i would not call it coordination but at
the same time we do see that they are
not uh targeting with their missiles the
transit infrastructure so they are
destroying our distribution
infrastructure creating humanitarian
crisis all over ukraine but they uh make
sure that their missiles do not hit the
transit infrastructure because they want
to keep
this
revenue stream uh to their regime that
is coming from experts of russian gas
and oil
you touched on this but how bad is the
gas
supply or the gas supply issues
in your country in terms of getting gas
throughout the country
on one hand we have enough gas in our
storage we have sizable local production
so we don't have any scarcity of gas at
the moment but what we have a problem
with it's the distribution
infrastructure as i mentioned because in
order to get gas to our consumers we
need distribution networks we need
heating plants that would then produce
uh
hot water out of gas and unfortunately
in the areas
where there is some heavy fight
over there
again the russian army deliberately
targets the pipelines the plans
distribution stations and
we had to cut off many of our consumers
in some casing the infrastructure cases
infrastructure was so damaged and
destroyed that there was no way to
deliver gas to our customers
is there anything you can do to to
rectify those issues is there any appeal
you can make to the eu for more
supplies or any sort of technical help
or is it just a matter of those areas
being in conflict
at first again we made this request but
in
majority of cases frankly again the
damage was uh
so serious that we need to rebuild it
and
in many areas heavy fights continue
in in other areas where for example
russian troops had to leave because of
the ukrainian army we're now trying to
restore the infrastructure
currently with our own resources
we would welcome of course any
international assistance uh we
understand that it's coming probably
just uh
too slow but for example in march alone
uh nafta gas uh the company that
i have owner to manage uh spend 1.3
billion dollars as basically subsidies
to uh our consumers as um investments
into infrastructure just to maintain it
so that people in ukraine uh were able
to get enough gas
all right yuri fitranko is ceo of
naftalgas ukraine thank you for joining
us
thank you
europe is desperately searching for
natural gas to replace those russian
imports
on paper at least the continent's
largest gas field beneath the dutch city
of groningen would appear to be a good
option
but years of drilling there have had a
devastating side effect earthquakes
triggered by changes in pressure
last week i visited groningen to speak
with residents about their experiences
lawrence mengerik gives me a tour of his
home it's falling apart
in that 2014 everything was repaired
everything was fine again
so after 2014 it happened everything
again
that you get these cracks
cracks in the window frames
in the walls
in the glass panes themselves
a pair of wooden braces is now the only
thing holding the house together
lawrence lives in a small village
outside of groningen in the northern
part of the netherlands
for years small earthquakes have rippled
throughout the region the culprit a
joint natural gas drilling project by
shell and exxonmobil
the dutch government says it intends for
all drilling to end next year at a time
when europe is desperate for more gas
europe's largest gas field rests three
kilometers beneath my feet
decades of drilling here has left scars
across this region it's also left people
here frustrated and even angry at their
own government
at the same time everyone understands
how problematic russian gas imports are
for all of europe
they just wonder what it means for the
region
and for their homes
it's estimated that just under half a
trillion cubic meters of natural gas
remain in the ground beneath groningen
but production has been throttled back
in recent years due to the earthquakes
to about an eighth of what it was just a
decade ago
according to one survey taken at the
beginning of russia's war with ukraine a
majority of residents in groningen would
support an uptick in gas production
but compensation is a big issue here
drilling has been lucrative for the
state while home repairs across the
region have been slow
and hampered by bureaucracy
if i read one of those george tacoma is
a professor at the university of
groningen
he believes locals could be open to more
drilling it started 2003
i think they
want to
to contribute
to solutions of the problem
but it depends very much on the way they
will be treated and respected in their
own
sorrows and the problems they have here
back in his village lawrence mengerich
has a similar idea about what should
happen now
to my opinion
we can open the gas
tap and to take out more gas but then
from the finance profits we should have
a fund raising for uh
repairing the house that gets damaged
yeah you see the same and maybe one day
he'll also be able to repair the damages
in his own home
[Music]
british energy conglomerate bp has
doubled its revenues for the first
quarter raking in six and a quarter
billion u.s dollars thanks to soaring
oil prices
but the group has posted a net loss of
more than 20 billion dollars for the
quarter after decided to exit russia
over the country's invasion of ukraine
in february bp pulled its stake in
energy group rosneft close to 20 percent
ending more than three decades of
investment in russia
spencer welsh is an oil consultant and
analyst for s p global he joins me now
spencer thanks for coming on the show
so is this a banner time for oil majors
like bp or is it an especially different
difficult one giving these these market
swings and these abandoned investments
through the war in ukraine
um
hi good to be with you i think it is um
it's a challenging time um but i guess
it's not unusual if you if we look back
at
oil prices or gas prices or almost any
commodity it's really flat it's it's
often up and down and so at one moment
companies can appear to be doing
extremely well and the next moment um
things are challenging you know as we
just heard with bp um they may be they
are benefiting from high oil and gas
prices but then there's the challenges
of of having to to
dispose of their their business in
russia so it's um highly volatile
these companies have now a lot of cash
on their books because of these high
prices how are they using that
um i guess different strategies bps
announced that they are going to be
doing some um share buybacks um which
essentially uh helps to increase the the
um the price of their of their their
shares for for their investors um bp's
also announced that they are using the
money to reduce their debt i think both
of those strategy strategies will be
similar for for other um companies um i
would imagine the the third thing is
preparing for the the energy transition
because um these oil and energy
companies are right at the forefront of
of needing to decarbonize
needing to move away from from oil and
gas
and that is it that isn't free that
requires investment
and so i'm sure they will be um
saving some of the the money now to help
help them
make that energy transition
all right spencer welch there with smp
global thank you very much
thank you